all right hello everyone I'm super
excited to be here as Mike said my name
is Neil Fournier I'm the head of
engineering at Rent the Runway I was
supposed to be joined by my colleague
colleague Carlo unfortunately or well
fortunately his wife had a baby on
Saturday so he's you know happily at
home with wife and baby and they're all
doing well but I am on my own for this
talk so you'll have to forgive me in the
latter half was really some content that
he created and so you'll have to forgive
me if I'm a little more vague than you
may like on that content but hopefully I
can do him justice so you know as Mike
said I'm here to talk about the way that
Rent the Runway does our web services
and sort of the evolution to a
service-oriented architecture that we
took and you know how we got to where we
are now it's really a case study right I
came in to the company a couple of years
ago and we were just really starting to
see see ourselves need to do a big
rewrite and so you know this is a little
bit about that and some of the decisions
we made in particular drop was or why we
chose to use drop wizard our experiences
with using that so how many of you are
familiar with read the runway okay
so pretty pretty good a number of you
which is great I love to hear that for
those of you who have never heard of
Rent the Runway you know our business is
about delivering Cinderella experiences
our goal what we offer is a product
where women can go on our website and
rent high-end designer dresses for a
fraction of the retail price for a short
term rental so you have an event on
Saturday you go onto our website find
something that you love to rent it you
know shows up in the mail for you on
Thursday or Friday
you know you try it on pick out your
shoes go to your event get a million
pictures taken look fabulous on Facebook
you know ship it back to us and you
don't have yet another dress sitting in
your closet you know shaming you for not
wearing it more than once and this is a
great business we have a amazing
customer base we have a lot you know we
we've done great things with this idea
but it's a business that was built by
two non-technical founders our founders
Jen and Jenny and both from Harvard
Business School and they came in you
know with this idea and they were like
well the technology should be not
trivial we know that technology is an
important part of this business but you
know there's so many other hard parts of
this business right the operation side
the marketing side the brand-building
side the technology is it's not that big
a deal so in the beginning there was
Drupal and Drupal is what our site was
originally built on and how many of you
are familiar with Drupal so fortunately
a half of you are not consider
yourselves lucky that you've not had to
work in Drupal particularly miss apply
Drupal which is where we were so Drupal
is a content management system for
written in PHP it is a great product for
certain things I think perhaps if you
were doing a very simple ecommerce
website Drupal is great Rent the Runway
is far from a simple ecommerce website
we have a lot of complexity around our
basic model right we're not actually
selling things or we're selling a few
things but mostly our business is
rentals right so right there straight
out the gate you've got a big set of
technology that has really you know no
standard components out there we had to
write all of that technology and Drupal
you know it's a content management
system the idea it's a little bit like
you know rails only you know worse much
worse arguably and everything is
everywhere you know it's one gigantic
monolithic system so you've got you know
your view layer with like literally HTML
and PHP sort of interspersed in code you
know you create and Moe own your users
your product creation your login your
filtering reservations was logic was in
there order management product details
was on that and so when I joined Rent
the Runway in the fall of 2011 you know
we were really in the Drupal world we
had the Drupal monolith and it was
making our lives very very very
miserable because we had gotten to a
point where it was very difficult for
the tech team to
actually change things successfully you
know part of this is just the technical
debt of you know what happens in a very
early stage of a startup you rapidly
bright code you know you may or may not
write tests really well or at all you
have just sort of throwing code in there
seeing it work
get it getting it to go getting it to go
because you're trying to figure out if
that business is gonna work or not well
you know we had Drupal and we were their
business was working but we were not
really able to make any more check
changes because it was just so difficult
to change things you've changed
something over here and something over
here would break and it would take a day
of debugging to figure out why in the
world this had any effect on that so in
the beginning we had Drupal but we also
had all of these lovely people who are
our customers
right this is a screenshot of one of our
more recent features which is our runway
where you can actually shop our site
based on pictures of women in our
dresses and real women you know people
who have really rented our dresses right
our customers were loyal and you know
fanatic and growing rapidly and so we
had this Drupal site it was slow it was
really slow and not particularly
beautiful and yet we also had this
rapidly faithful and growing customer
base that was willing to you know jump
through hoops and deal with the slowness
of our site and deal with the bugginess
of our site in order to be able to rent
I like to tell a story about one time I
broke the page in between when you add
something to your cart and your checkout
so that you just got a blank page and we
still had people check out successfully
like a lot of people very few people
abandoned us at that point and that to
me was like wow you know Hugh you know I
didn't cost us that much money normally
a breakage like that you know you're
done right people are not going to chase
your product down and make it work for
them so we have this really rapid but
loyal fan base but what this really
meant is that we couldn't just burn the
world down we go we would have liked to
pour gasoline all over those zukul
servers light a match walk away and do
something different but the fact of the
matter is that was not possible for us
we had a business we had a big
successful and growing business
running on those old Drupal servers so
we had to do something else and the way
that we chose to address this problem
was basically to hollow it out so
instead of rewriting everything all at
once and just you know doing a big bang
code over we took out pieces of
functionality from Drupal and rewrote
them as Java services so we rewrote our
reservation server we rewrote our
product catalog we rewrote you know our
filtering and we chose to do this we did
this in Java why did we do it in Java
versus some other language we had people
that knew Java
I think Java is a perfectly fine
programming language you know I am a
Java person I know Java very well
there's something to be said for the
senior people in your team what language
do they know really really really well
and going with that language it's
extremely scalable you know I like the
JVM could we have chosen scholar or
closure or something else perhaps but at
this time those languages were still
quite new and I feel no you know no
sadness for having gone with Java but we
were building these Java services to
pull functionality out of Drupal and
this was actually you know this was
great this was really you know it was
not easy it was took us a long time it
was kind of a big effort particularly
our reservation system which you know as
you can imagine is a really really key
and important part of our business we
chose to not only take that logic out of
Drupal but actually also rewrite its
functionality at the same time and you
know word to the wise I would not
recommend generally speaking doing that
at the same time everything past that
we've chosen to take out and then add
new functionality versus taking out and
rewriting at the same time because that
ended up being a really big difficult
project but you know we took these
projects out we rewrote them we wrote
them in Java we made them basically JSON
API so our Drupal server now you delete
it all this PHP code it called these
JSON endpoints and great beautiful
wonderful this is actually not a bad way
if you've got a reaaargh attacked a
system and you want to move
to a solar system not about all a bad
way to do it but it has a downside and a
downside that I knew I recognized sort
of from the get-go which is complexity
and this is the this is my
embarrassingly poor data visualization
graph because if you notice this axis is
as a joke this isn't not good but the
moral of the story of this graph is that
the number of services we had in
production was about 2 in December of
2011 and that was one extremely trivial
service around experiments and something
that we had actually had an outsourcer
create around our photo reviews by March
of 2012 we were up to six services in
production and by May 2012 we were up to
11 services in production and now today
we have about 12 services again for our
web stack layer we also have you know a
huge number of services running our
warehouse and operations side software
and that's a whole it's a whole
different system but fortunately always
written in Java so we didn't quite have
the same problem there so you may look
at this and think yourself as well so
you treated something for something here
you had this horrible Drupal stack that
nobody could get anything done but now
you've got 12 different types of
services in production
are you insane like that does not
actually seem any easier to me and you
know you're right in some sense right we
are we definitely traded the complexity
of you know developers being able to get
any work done so in this model right now
our developers are able to get work done
actually quite quickly I'm able to say
you are gonna focus on some feature that
needs product work you're gonna focus on
something needs reservations work you're
gonna focus on something that affects
our users and it's generally speaking
people can work much better in parallel
without worrying about stepping on each
other's toes not perfectly not a hundred
percent but certainly significantly
better than we were on the Drupal world
yes you had a quick question
sure the so the question is when they
separate from the data model perspective
they're sharing the same database so the
way that I structured the services we
have data owning services so all of the
crud around certain types of data
related types of data will be owned by a
single service so a reservation service
our product service our users service we
also actually have integration services
that will that don't generally do any
data themselves they take data from
other services and combine them in
various ways for example if you're
thinking about a the product filtering
right so our product faceting and
filtering you need to get products from
the product catalog you need to sort
them based on attributes but you may
also need to check their reservation
availability or you may need to say show
me only the ones that this user has
favorited so we have integration
services that will actually combine data
from different services and deliver JSON
payloads to the front line it's not
perfectly clean but that model has
actually worked pretty well for us and
they do actual share the database is
shared but various tables will be
strictly partitioned to the services
that use them and we have not had any
trouble via code review and sort of
convention keeping people from violating
that so complexity we've got a lot of
services in production and I knew that
this was going to happen I have you know
a background in so architectures and
distributed systems from prior work so
you know I came in being aware that we
were gonna lose some of the simplicity
of operations benefits that you get from
a monolith system so monolith systems
you know they have their own operational
complexities but you buy a ton of extra
complexity anytime you're adding Network
hops and sort of conversations between
servers to part of your stack and
particularly if you have lots of
different types of services you've all
decided and bought a lot of complexity
right it's more difficult to tell if
something is running slow why is it
running slow right if something's giving
back slightly incorrect
where is that coming from you know
you've got a failure somewhere in your
stack where what's failing and why and
what do you need to do to bring it back
up and so the way that I chose to
address this particular issue was to
think really operations first in the
design and the choices that we made
building out our services so you know
DevOps right is a very popular concept
these days I think for good reasons
right I think DevOps is a great way of
you know forcing everyone to think about
the way that your code is actually going
to be deployed and running in production
I think every developer should have a
really good mental model for what that
means availability and performance of
your services is a critical you know
aspect of actually serving your business
the software that you develop it has to
meet the SLA is that your customers need
right you've got a website but it's
really really slow in the e-commerce
world that is dollars spent so
understanding you know where you're
spending those dollars and you know
understanding what's slow and how to fix
it is an incredibly important thing that
every developer of a service needs to be
at least somewhat aware of they need to
be thinking operationally how is this
gonna run what's gonna happen how can
this break what is it talking to and how
can it break so how do you deal with
this obviously besides sort of trying to
have some sanity in your design and
sanity and the design means you really
don't want like circular references of
your services service ax to be tux to C
talks to a talks to be you know that's
that's a really bad idea you want to
keep it sort of in a tree if possible
but you also want things like health
checks and naggy o so you want to know
our my server is okay or my service is
running are they are they healthy are
they able to talk to the other services
that they need to talk to you need to be
able to measure the performance of your
services how the endpoints are
performing how things are going you know
what's what's going on right how many
threads are being used what's the memory
usage and you need to combine those
measurements with historical data and
graphics so you need to actually not
only know what's happening right at this
second but when something goes wrong you
need to be able to answer the question
is if that's the first time it's gone
wrong or is this something that we've
been having
with for a long time so thinking
operations first is really important now
the first place that I sort of thought
about this it was actually again in our
reservation service which is one of our
very earliest services and reservations
you'll have to take my word for this
because I'm this is that's possibly the
most secret sauce of our whole business
but reservations is a big slow difficult
problem if you've ever gone on to Zipcar
for example or even kayak and searched
for availability of a flight or a car or
a hotel room or whatever it actually
takes a while in terms of you know web
time those searches actually take rather
a long time and so too does our
reservation search it's a very
complicated database query around what's
you know what's rented what's in
people's parts what's rented before what
started after what's coming back win
that's a pretty complex system and we
were having performance issues while we
were testing out this system where
things were just like not performing
quite where we needed them to and we had
this issue with the load balancers we
were using would actually snipe queries
after 30 seconds so we would have
queries failing and it was hard to tell
did it fail because the query that was
made was incorrect
that it failed because the query just
took longer than 30 seconds to run yeah
that's really bad made worse by the fact
that our staging environment databases
were much slower than our production
databases so you know we've got all this
like nastiness around performance and we
needed to understand what was going on
and so I came across this library called
metrics from Yammer a company called
Yammer and it's you know if you search
Yammer metrics you'll find it and this
library is a really nice simple Java
library that has a number of little
things in it it has a bunch of different
ways things for measuring right so
counters how often is something been
called meters what's the rate over time
right like you know how often in the
last second was this thing called
histograms right so what's the you know
tie rate over 95%
Tyl of a time something and was running
timers all sorts of really useful little
simple but incredibly useful things for
your services it also has a very nice
little thing called health checks where
you actually can say this is what it
means for my service to be healthy and
register that someplace where you can
then ping it with something like Nagios
and say are my healthy or not you can
use this report via HTTP it actually
exports to jmx and if you happen to have
graphite set up which is very useful
then you can actually be capturing this
and have a historical record of what the
performance of your service has been so
I found this because we were working
with not drop wizard at the time so that
our framework of the time was the play
1.2 framework and you know for those of
you unfamiliar with the play framework
the if you search the play framework
right now mostly what you're gonna find
out about is a play 2 framework lay two
framework in the play 1.2 poem are
totally different frameworks to play 1.2
framework was an attempt just to sort of
create something that was like Ruby on
Rails for Java a little bit so it was oh
you can get up running really really
fast well like generate an application
for you you can modify code and you know
while your service is running and
redeploy it and you know all of that
stuff which is generally in my opinion
not actually a good idea to do in Java
Java as a language really meant for that
kind of kind of manipulation and we were
using the play framework and we're not
using the play framework anymore partly
because the play framework turned into
the play to framework and play one was
simply not really very well supported it
was kind of abandoned where and so I had
come across this metric library from
Yammer and I really liked it I mean put
it in play we were really unhappy with
play and I was like we really need to
move to something new
and I came across this cool thing by the
same guy that wrote metrics his name is
Kota Heil
it's called drop wizard and I was like
oh drop quizzer this is interesting
I like Kota I think he's a very smart
guy
I read the source code for metrics and
was very impressed with how clean it was
how easy it was to read and I thought
you know what if someone with that sort
of good head on his shoulders is writing
a framework I should take a look at it
so what is drop wizard Drakh wizard is
essentially a very very simple
lightweight way to to run make java web
frameworks java web services so it's
open source java products glued together
best-in-class products it eliminates the
need for picking in platform stacks you
don't just side am I gonna use jetty am
I gonna use Tomcat am I gonna use which
of the JSON libraries I'm gonna use it
gives you the best-in-class of all of
those if you don't like those core
components drop wizard is not the
framework for you right it's fairly
opinionated in that way it allows
developers to focus on business logic
not the framework so much of course I
think every framework tries to say that
but you know succeed with varying
degrees of success it is pretty easy to
use though very maintainable and it has
worked extremely well for us so when I
was preparing this talk you know I
actually reached out to coda and asked
him why he built droppers in the first
place I was like well you know here's
why I chose it because I think if you
got hit by a bus I could still support
the code and I like the simplicity of it
but why did you build it in the first
place when there are so many other java
web frameworks out there and he wrote
back a really great response and it
included this you know he had no one to
toss the war to I had no one to stand up
a tomcat server and fiddle with it until
their eyes blood I had no one who didn't
trust me to spit up my own thread pools
or connection pools so I wrote something
which worked as simply and an in as
straightforward a manner as possible
because my own ass was on the line if it
didn't work and I don't you know
hopefully many of you are in the startup
community you know that feeling of
yourself being on the line you are the
one on the line if it doesn't work you
don't have a giant team of people that
are going to support your software you
know
soup to nuts after you throw it over the
wall to them right it's yours it's yours
to run it's yours to maintain it's yours
to support you better be running
something that you feel comfortable
supporting so what is in drop wizard the
basic ingredients of tapas are jersey
forest Jackson for JSON Jenny for a web
server metrics for measuring the animal
for configuration and drop wizards for
weaving everything together there are
additional things that you can use with
droplet or that has jdb I support it as
of recently has hibernate support
there's a few other things I can't even
think of right but these are sort of the
very core ingredients if you want to
make a nice little restful JSON serving
Java service this is what you need and
drop Wizard combines it very very nicely
from an Operations perspective that
metrics piece is really important
because not only does it provide metrics
but it basically will nag you if you
aren't doing operational best practices
such as creating health checks so health
checks are registered as part of
application creation if you don't
register a health check the startup will
warn you and yell at you every single
time you start up you don't have any
health checks why don't you have any
health checks health checks are just
simply HTTP endpoints that iterate over
various hooks that you create and you
say what the meaning of healthiest so
you can basically create the help check
that always returns healthy as long as
the service is running that's fine or
you can be a little bit smarter and say
I'm going to I need a database I better
be able to have a connection to the
database I'm gonna put a database check
in there I'm gonna make sure that I
don't have too many client connections
but that I can accept client connections
I'm gonna make sure I don't have any
thread dead locks so that's a bad that's
a bad one if you got dead locks
I'm going off that's not good you know
draw boozer has additional metrics baked
into it so that you can really easy anis
easily annotate your restful endpoints
to get timings off of them right it also
has metrics baked into all the core JVM
components so you've got metrics around
your JVM metrics around your logging
metrics around your client connections
that's really really useful because now
you've got this thing that's
automatically outputting all the stuff
you need
to really understand operationally what
is going on with your service so I
promised when I pitched this talk that I
would talk about some of the other
frameworks we tried so I will admit that
we have run all of these types of
frameworks in production I rent the
runway I am perhaps more permissive or
perhaps just you know whatever we ran
play 1.2 we still actually run play 1.2
in production on services that we
haven't bothered to migrate to drop
wizard it's been it's abandoned where
this is why we're not using it you know
there's just a little bit too much magic
and it's a little bit too difficult to
debug
yes back so the question is would be
experiments Plato we did a very little
bit when we were looking to choose our
next platform
Plato was in very beta and we were
actually talked to members of the play
community and they advised us not to go
with Plato so it just never the timing
would play to tato never worked out for
us we did however spin up GlassFish why
did we spend up GlassFish well we spawn
a blast this because when we started
using drop wizard it did not support
hibernate or any kind of ORM and that
was actually and is actually important
to my team we have data that's in Drupal
database Drupal is like super super a
relational super super normalized kind
of data structures oh our M's work
really well with that kind of data
structure it's really kind of difficult
to write straight sequel to it so we
needed something with an ORM and you
know we wanted to reduce drop wizard and
other things but we were like well we
need some of them we don't want to use
anymore play so the question was do we
use glass fissure do we use spring which
is was and is still and used in our
warehouse side and blast fish you know
the developers would often came back and
said we want to try GlassFish we had
someone that had
familiar with GlassFish I would
absolutely not recommend GlassFish at
this point I would never ever choose
that have a rather used spring than
GlassFish it just was it's so it's so
weird that a system that is standards
and it's like implementing the Java
standards it's so difficult for people
who are used to writing Java services to
work with but the fact of the matter is
it was I don't know if it's the OSGi I
don't know if it's sort of the
administrative console but we had a lot
of difficulty with GlassFish I'm sure
it's great if you've got a great
expertise in-house of people using it it
was definitely not for us the challenge
was spring in my opinion is that spring
is a huge library full of many huge
framework with many many many components
to it you know it's been around for a
long time and therefore has collected
some cruft over the years and I hate XML
with a burning burning passion I want as
a little XML as possible in my life I
realized spring has whittled down the
amount of XML on one needs to use it but
it's still there and I still hate it so
you know we tried other frameworks but
we've been really happy drop what is the
one we have we have centralized on that
we have all agreed across the
development team we prefer to use we
prefer to write code in we've actually
moved all of our GlassFish services into
drop wizard all new services both in our
warehouse stack and in our website stack
are in drop wizard now and eventually
all these play old play services will be
moved to drop wizards as well so we've
been really very happy with it did you
have a question in the back
yeah
so the question is to be considered not
using a framework at all and that's a
great question I like to have a little
something so you know drop Wizard is
really about the minimal amount that you
can get without not having a framework
and I do think that it's nice not to
have to think about how you're gluing
everything together and have every
developer when they're starting a new
project up do something different so you
know I do think that having something of
a framework is nice I do think I also
think the drop boys are just right now
as far as I am aware like the simplest
framework that you can get out there
that's still really a framework as
opposed to just you know both in JSON
onto a web server as you said so this is
the point in the talk in which I would
have given the stage over to my
colleague Carlo but it said you'll have
to deal with me going over really the
developer perspective of what our
development development team might say
they get out of this I have written code
on the draw buzzards but I'm also
managing of a large team so I don't
write a lot of code these things so what
is the developer agenda why would a
developer team want to use drop Wizard
especially a development team that's
responsible for some operational side
things and the answer is you know
there's a few things right it helps with
storytelling it's an integration will be
an integral piece of the operational
excellence puzzle gives you a good
access to state of the world allows the
developers to focus on features and the
operations side to be mostly free lunch
and I'm gonna go a little bit over some
drop wizard code give you a little tiny
micro demo this flamer here is important
you do need Graphite's harness the value
of drop wizard fully and graphite is a
tiny bit of a pain in the butt to set up
the first time you get it set up but
it's really valuable so storytelling
what do you mean well I don't know about
you guys but as often happens in my
office someone will say or send an email
the grid is slow meaning our address
rest filter hood is slow why the site is
slow things seem to be going slow why is
it going slow
now sometimes the answer is the internet
and our office is too slow and it is
fully you know fully taken over by all
the people in the office streaming
YouTube to their computers so that's why
the site feels slow it has nothing to do
with our technology but sometimes it
really is slow and now you have to
figure out why is it slow is it the load
is some dependent service giving a bunch
of latency back to the server's do we
have something weird going on in the
JavaScript layer so understanding what's
caused that story to happen is very
important you know the JVM is starting
an out of memory exception what's the
problem what does it JVM usage look like
historically have we actually always
been sort of using more and more memory
every time you restart but we just
didn't bother to notice our we have a
correlation with increased load and we
get these out of memory errors how is
that new performance tweak how often
have you done this I'm gonna improve
performance in production I didn't
bother to get a baseline of performance
in production right now but I'm sure
this optimisation is gonna make things
faster I'm sure many of you in this
audience have done that I know because I
just had someone do that to me very
recently and I think you probably didn't
make it faster but it's very hard to
tell because we didn't bother to get
baseline numbers if you've never
measured you're not tuning performance
you're just sort of throwing darts in
the general area of performance so you
may hit the bull's eye but if you don't
know what your performance is now you
can't really improve it in any
meaningful way right so understanding
what your performance is being able to
tell the story around performance is
really important this is important by
the way when you're at my level and
talking to other members of your
executive team about the health of your
website and the health of your
technology team being able to say oh we
improved the performance of our website
from five seconds to four seconds or you
know two seconds 2.5 seconds that's a
really important and valuable story to
be able to tell because you know even
non-technical people appreciate numbers
like that
the ingredients of operational
excellence application instrumentation
so this is again why did we use drop us
or why do we like drop Buzzard and why
do we feel that is an important part of
our web service stack because it
automatically gives you this application
instrumentation that's really important
for understanding the quality of the
code that you're writing the health of
your systems and all of that you can
give yourself application and
cementation via the metrics library so
for those of you who are Java developers
and want to take away and you can't just
change the plain framework for platform
that you're writing on please at least
take away the metrics library it's
really really useful and it can give you
some of this it's gonna be harder to
integrate with a secondary system but
it's something and it's really really
valuable if you care about operational
excellence taking that application
instrumentation and combining it with
time series data and graphing via
something like graphite is an additional
you know very powerful thing for
operational excellence right that lets
you know how was I doing last week how
am i doing this week right when my load
Peaks how does everything look I made a
release has anything changed in my
operational characteristics then the
other ingredients that we're still
working on but hopefully you guys have
amazing companies and you're like on the
ball of the Ops gained centralized
logging and log parsing and automatic
alerting and escalation via page of duty
and not via emails which is what we do
right now and everyone hates us for it
but drop wizard in graphite though those
first two things will get you very far
down the operational excellence path so
if you really care about you know
operational excellence at least getting
something with applications for mutation
and getting some sort of time series and
historical data out there is great this
is a real question that we've had to ask
ourselves oh my God we're on Good
Morning America is everything okay
Rent the Runway has a fabulous PR team
which means that sometimes our founders
go on to massive market TV shows and we
get 10,000 people going to read through
an wacom all at the same time when
you've got 10 servers or more than 10
servers and each server running in
cluster behind a load balancer
understanding the meaning of okay and
being able to answer this question
especially in the heat of the moment can
be really difficult and the best way to
do that is to have a lot of information
at your fingertips and the best way to
get information really is visually
aggressively so you want to have some
dashboards right screams screams ooh
graphite graphite is very ugly but very
powerful these this is a sample of our
graphite dashboard for our integration
service it has such things as the uptime
nice increasing number that's a bit too
good you know it has things like our
tenured generation so for those of you
familiar with Java and DC patterns right
it's big and then it gets carbon so you
can see that's great our five hundred
counts you know calls per seconds all
sorts of pieces of information that you
can at a glance see sort of what the
health of your systems are and if you're
familiar with reading these graphs you
can know very quickly oh that does not
look good like that one service on that
box is really going crazy for some
reason it's garbage collecting all over
the place why is that so graphite
provides you with this ability to at
least see these numbers you know see the
historical changes and watch them over
time but an even better thing is simply
red yellow and green right so tasse o is
a dashboard I think out of github that's
the original author this is even nicer
right you pipe your graphite data into
Tassie oh and now all you're looking for
is is everything green good I'm good
everything green good I'm good now
that's you know if you're trying to look
for sort of worrying patterns this may
or may not be the best thing but it
gives you a very good at a glance
quality right if you see yellow or red
you want to start diagnosing because
something is starting to go wrong
so operational excellence if you're
going to run a service-oriented
architecture and you're going to you
know have 10 12 15 20 services and
production hopefully we'll never get to
20 but you know 10 or 12 you really need
to be able to quickly see the health of
your entire system and again it cannot
just be you know your ops people in the
corner toiling away your whole
development staff needs to understand
and appreciate the operational picture
of course there's not actually any such
thing as a free lunch you know you still
have to think about all the things that
you need to monitor and you know how
you're going to actually collect all
that information again drop wizard gives
you a lot of this for free but you need
to be collecting it paying attention to
it and knowing what you're gonna be
paying attention to so if you want to do
this you know how do you get this
happening in your environment well you
have to install graphite graphite is a
pain in the butt to install but once you
get over that one time hit and a little
bit of TLC it's it's great it's fabulous
I'm really a big graphite fan then all
you need to do is annotate your end
points add some telemetry configure your
services so that they're all feeding
graphite and hopefully you do this in a
centralized manner so you've got some
core libraries that are going to all
your services and then get sort of the
graphite piece for free they just have
to add the appropriate element to you
and you're done now you've got this you
know operational platform for your web
services feeding all the information you
need and it's sort of baked in out of
the box every time a new developer spins
up a new service so that at that this
point I'm going to very quickly show you
a little bit of dropper xored code if
you would like otherwise I'm happy to
answer questions right now before I go
into that anything yes
ok yes yes I think that's something
that's one right out of graphite yeah so
Tatsuya was a rapper but I don't I think
the one that's just the line graphs is
the straight out of graphite sorry that
was a question was when we were showing
that line graph what where is that
visualization coming from I'm pretty
sure it's straight out of graphite yeah
yes I believe that you set you've set
thresholds I did not set up the task oh
that's a that's a Carlo a piece of
expertise but yes I believe that you set
thresholds so that you actually know you
know sort of what what's healthy and
what is it yeah if you could figure it
out on its own that would be awesome but
I don't I don't think the Machine can do
that quite yet yeah
yeah
so the question is like from a coding
perspective how do you manage
development across the team when you've
got your code split into services so we
did a few things I mean first of all the
services are now all in their own
separate sort of repositories so we have
you know a github for the organization
and we have a ridiculous number of
repositories given how many developers
ago I think we have like three
repositories per developers a little bit
out of control
so we do have versioning in that every
time service is a release to production
you tag the release with a particular
version you tell everyone you know the
version that's being tagged and you
release it we don't actually at this
point we have never yet had an issue
where we actually had to upgrade
services and lock step so we don't have
any versioning dependencies in our
servers yet someday I have no doubt
we'll get there but right now we've
managed to write everything to be
backward compatible in appropriate ways
so that you know you can upgrade a
service and you know very rarely do you
have to upgrade other services in
lockstep with that you know this that is
though a aspect of complexity that I
expect that we are gonna have to be
solving better in the near future we do
I mean we do use maven for sort of jars
and dependencies and I think one of the
big challenges of doing a
service-oriented architecture in
particular if you start getting to any
kind of like binary communication we
just use JSON so that makes life very
very easy is versioning of your client
libraries and creation of your client
libraries and how do you you know how do
you get you know if service a is talking
to service B service a needs the client
for service B to service a write that
client internally or does it take a jar
from service B version a you know how do
you manage that complexity that is
fortunately something that we have not
I had to deal with yet but I have no
doubt we will at some point in the
future yes I mean we're not at that but
the point of performance tuning where we
care about the overhead the JSON part of
the overhead right it's just the value
of putting a binary representation into
our systems and adding that complexity
adding you know whatever it is you need
to do to make that work versus the
lovely ease of debug ability of JSON is
just right now it's not one said to us
it I may very well be at some point in
the future yes right so the question is
has our release process changed it has
to some degree so I try very hard when I
you know when I was working in the
back-end services and naturally the part
of the system that I started in when I
started at the company to make it so
that those services could be released at
any time and for the most part they are
actually still in that state for our
website the services should always be
tested and you know qualified on their
own terms by their developers and able
to be released at any time and you know
believe it or not but that has actually
been totally fine by and large right we
have very rarely had an instance where a
service has been deployed and QA has
found something that has gone
drastically drastically wrong we still
do weekly releases and so often it's
just easiest to do everything at once
our warehouse side does weekly releases
and they they are much more back in
focused so they do everything at once in
the QA at all together but you know it's
my goal is really to get us to more of a
continuous deployment model and so
everything I do is working towards that
and you know I think therefore like
we've got to have some parts of our
system where the developers really own
quality top to bottom and they should be
able to deploy those
at any time yes
sure so because we exposed to services
how do we deal with security actually we
don't just expose the services to the
public so we have a way of routing
requests from our front ends to our
services so that we are only oh we are
only actually whitelisting certain IP
addresses into our services so we have
you know load balancers in between that
are actually you know vetting traffic so
know the services themselves are not
whitelisted to the internet right only
IP addresses from our own front-end
machines are able to talk to these
services yeah
yeah sure so the question is what did I
learn about reorganizing the team in
this process the team used to be
organized in really so we had a
front-end team that kind of old owned
the old Drupal and all of the you know
UI and website stuff and all of that
complexity we had a service to this
infrastructure team that owned all the
new services as they were being built
and then we had a warehouse operations
team as we've gone down the path of this
process we've actually been able to
reorganize everyone to be in more
cross-functional teams so that they're
supporting parts of the business and
business goals instead of supporting
like a particular piece of software so
that's actually great for the developers
because now they're really integrated
with the business very closely and
they're supporting sort of front to back
like how often do people add items to
their cart we have teams from dedicated
to business metrics as opposed to saying
you're an infrastructure team you own
services or you own the database or you
own whatever right it's a it's a much
more top-to-bottom and cross functional
organization yeah where are we hosting
we are hosting in Rackspace we are you
know most of our back-end and front-end
stuff is in Rackspace we actually do
have we've moved to Ruby 10 clients for
most of our actual web UI and that's all
in Heroku or Engine Yard so that's sort
of a departure but most of our services
are actually in practice base yes
yeah if I was gonna start from scratch
what would I change about my
architecture it's a big question
I'm actually pretty I'm pretty happy
with the way our architecture has been
done it is right now you know there's
not one glaring area where I think this
is really awful I think if I were really
gonna start from scratch I would think
more about how can I build the system so
that we can do continuous deployment
like what automation do I need to put in
place to be able to do that or what
cultural changes do I need to make to be
able to do that because I think
continuous deployment is as much a
factor of the culture of your entire
organization as it is about your tech
but I think you know from a tech
perspective I'm actually like you know
I'm pretty happy with the systems I
think we are we're at a really good
point where we are at risk of being too
complex but not there yet and I think
that's great because that means that
we're working in a very interesting
space we're working towards the edge of
our capabilities and we're expanding our
capabilities so actually you know I mean
I have to say I'm I'm pretty pleased
with the way our system is architected
right now yeah yeah
are we running in Hadoop clusters or
data analysis we are not reading any
Hadoop clusters right now we do have
Vertica and some other data analytics
systems we are slowly working our way
into that world
but right now you know we we have Excel
we have one of my data scientists up
here making fun of her know we have we
are we are working on that but you know
honestly like a lot of the important
data for us is not Hadoop scale right a
lot of the important data for us can fit
into a big database and you can you know
if your team is comfortable with sequel
you can write sequel on it and our do
our analytics team a lot of them are
more comfortable in sequel but we're
working on you know expanding that so
yes what do we use for search we
actually so search as in text search is
actually a very very minor part of our
website so we actually use solar for it
but it's very it's pretty much only used
by our customer insights staff it's
really actually our customers themselves
don't use it because we have fake names
for all of our dresses so it's a very
you know the names for like this this is
a rental dress the name for this dress
might be like I don't know like swirly
swirly blue awesomeness or whatever and
like that's not the name that the
designer gave this dress that's just the
name that our branding and merchandising
team thought would be a good name for
this dress so it doesn't actually it's
not actually super meaningful so people
don't tend to come to our site and do a
lot of text searches but we do use solar
for what we have
I walk pointed we realized rule was not
working I mean I think everyone knew
that before I joined the company to be
to be honest right like you know when
you've got a team I think the team was
probably around ten sort of developers
at that point and the last five releases
have been almost not exactly epic fails
but like you know you're at least you
rolled back you released two days later
you rolled back you released a week
later everyone had been up all night
every night to get the last few bits of
it fixed and you finally have you know
gotten through it and then a month later
you try again and you go through that
every we've got because some people here
who lived through those days you know
when people are just coming to work and
they're dret you can tell when you tell
your tech team is dreading coming to
work you know you've got a lot of work
to do it's not even about like how fast
you can build stuff for you know the
website it's really like is you texting
hate coming to work or not they hate
coming to work you've got to worry about
your technology yeah
yes yeah sure so the current the current
status of our systems is we do have a
little bit of Drupal still out there
running some admin pages running like
our team page a couple of small places
we have a lot of thin Ruby Sinatra
clients that are very dumb they don't
talk to any databases they only talk to
services and they're serving the vast
majority of our you know web a customer
facing web infrastructure I'm sorry what
was the rest of the question yeah so the
evolution was that we we had built up a
bunch of services and we had gotten you
know some pretty we had gotten the
services to be pretty good and we
actually built a new product called our
runway which one of those slides earlier
was actually from so our runway is the
ability for people to shop our site
based on pictures of women in our
clothing and the our runway project was
totally new it was a totally new
architecture for us it was going to be
you know we could build it from scratch
and we didn't have to integrate it with
the rest of our site so we chose to
prove out a new model using that and I
basically you know which the development
team and said what what do we want to do
for this do we want to stay in PHP and
use a different PHP framework you know
do we want to try something new do we
want to do a java web primark you know I
mean I don't there's nothing wrong with
that but if your developers are used to
more scripting languages it's probably
not a great choice and developers
universally said we want to do Ruby and
I said okay you could do Ruby but I'm
not sure about rails can we try
something else and so we ended up one
Sinatra which is actually worked out
very well for us Sinatra sort of keeps
things from it keeps the temptation of
complexity away a little bit and you
know but it still gives our website
developers a language and a framework
that makes sense for that kind of work
so yes yes okay so if we run into any
issues coupling our service layer with
our DevOps layer I come from a
background where developed there is no
dedicated ops so developers are ops
there's that's just the background that
I come from so you know frankly with any
any complaints about that I was like why
are you whining but I mean it's true
that there are you know onboarding
developers who are used to an
environment where they are sort of
building something and putting it out
there and someone else is supporting it
there is a little bit of a cultural
teaching right you have to teach people
how to support all the time how to be
thinking about support all the time
meaning that not just when you're in
your on-call rota are you checking the
pages or checking the emails if
something's going wrong even just
occasionally even just a little bit
you better be putting that at the top of
your stack and so teaching developers
how to think that way there was some
just cultural adjustment there as for
DevOps as a service we actually use a
product called new relic that we
integrated with our drupal side and we
still use it on the Ruby side and we've
been really happy with that product to
help with some of our monitoring you
know it's it's a really nice product it
doesn't replace all of the stuff that we
get in our service layer but you know
that's an enhancement we have to our ops
side yes
so we had okay so question is did we
have graphite and metrics first or did
we have New Relic first and the answer
section we had Mirotic first so we've
had new relic for a long time because we
put new I like on the Drupal side as we
were you know cleaning it up but to help
us identify you know big slowness --iz
and problems with the Drupal side but
you know I I think I think New Relic is
great and it maybe will be that we're
not using it's very full potential but
I'm also more of a fan of the
annotations based monitoring versus
having like a je MPI or whatever library
loaded into your JVM which is what you
do with New Relic to monitor Java I'm a
little less of a fan of like that just
from historical bias it's probably
totally irrational but you know we all
have our historical biases so I prefer
to like know and be able to read the
code that is affecting any part of my
stack and not just sort of load
libraries into the command line that I
can't I can't interpret myself
yes the time kind of improvements to the
front of you and you just see in terms
of speed in reality this wasn't so much
of a speed play so we did improve
performance and like a couple of places
slightly I honestly don't have the
numbers off the top of my head the front
end user performance for us was more
about the features that we were able to
provide to the user and also like user
performance is really a lot we had a lot
of cruft in our JavaScript layer that
you know improving that minifying things
minifying our CSS minifying our
javascript like just doing doing the
right stuff at our javascript and CSS
layer made so much more of a difference
in performance than really the backend
play this was not a performance play per
se right like I think we couldn't turn
it into a performance play at some point
it was a scalability play and that
Drupal was not very scalable for us and
for burst traffic because Drupal ties
sessions to the physical server that
they were connected to at least the
version that we had so you couldn't just
spin up additional servers and throw
them into the pool to ease a big burst
of traffic on your Drupal stack without
logging people out so we had that
problem with Drupal we no longer have
that problem we can now web-scale both
our front ends and our back ends very
easily and just you know say oh
something's we're hitting a bunch of
load throw some more servers in the pool
you know and get that spun up so we have
much more scalability with our new new
stack but it's not so much of a
performance play I do think it's
improved performance but not like that
was the goal coming up yes
yes yes so the data access layer did we
use an RM yes we use hibernate yes so
drop wizard now has support for
hibernate and you know I think
hibernates fine it's been around for a
long time performance problems along
with queries yes not sometimes thanks to
hibernate
sometimes just due to direct queries
that we've written that are very very
complex that type of tuning usually we
catch it it's very rare that that will
get to production it's usually caught
you know in in testing and UAT
yes yes deployment harnesses we do use
Capistrano scripts we're not really into
the deployment harness level yet to be
honest we use them and we do have some
scripting some Capistrano scripting and
some of our other parts of the site use
use deployment harnesses but not not
really not that much yet do you guys
want to see a very quick like demo of
some drop Azure code all right I will
try to be very close this is going to be
panning us anyone know how to get my
screen to only just show my screen you
know I'm talking about how to get this
to just show this screen and not maybe
like
not or not a secondary screen
sorry gonna be just all right now it's
really small but okay so I think there's
you know there is a pretty good sort of
hello world demo on drop wizard Cody
Hale calm but I even stripped it down
even smaller it was bigger all right I
don't know how to make this bigger so
you're gonna have to forgive me
so what command shift plus no no love
all right so there's sort of a few basic
pieces that you need to care about with
drop wizard you need to pair about
configuration you need to care about the
actual resources I need to care about
the service or in the newer versions
it's actually called an application so
the configuration is the way you can
figure things right you have a
configuration Yambol file and this is
what you build up to pass into your
resources to configure them so this is a
hello world resource that we're building
up what is our hello world resource
build this is if you're familiar with
Jersey you've got a lot of Jersey
annotation so you've got your path hello
world it produces application JSON type
if you look at my resource here it's a
get resource get endpoints its time so
this is one of the metrics annotations
meaning that you're going to actually
capture timing and rate information on
this it's also exception metered so
you'll capture a metering of any
exceptions that come through this
endpoint will be captured separately you
can actually have
control headers in there which is pretty
nice and then this resource is hello
worlds you know end point returns is
saying which is JSON type which has a
counter and a template that's rendering
the string of your name so we're saying
hello to you what is our configuration
look like our configuration just takes
the string template so that's like a
string formatter and a default name if
you have no name what do I say hello to
in this case my default if I put nothing
in Miami would be partner I wish I could
I wish I could but I do not know how to
do that I don't think it's Eclipse I
think it's the how to do these things
sorry can you read it at all or not
sorry guys I'm you always want to do a
demo and it always goes poorly is this
better a little better this is a little
better right okay so sorry about that
I'll very quickly go back to our
resources so you can see this again you
see the jersey annotations hello world
producing application JSON this is an
endpoint it's a get in point it is time
which means that you're actually
annotating this with timed and you're
getting some timing information out of
this endpoint it's also exception meter
which means it will capture information
around the exceptions this is just a get
in points to say hello optional
parameter of a name and returns this
JSON object is saying which has a
counter and it renders the name to
configure this we have a template which
we're using in our hello world resource
it's going to configure how we actually
render what you in text we're gonna
print out it has a default name so
partner if you don't put a name in your
gamal this is what it will render to
glue it all together we actually have a
service this just gets initialized
bootstrapped up with a name you create
you build your templates out of your
configuration so the way that all these
services work is you create a
configuration file that knows how to
translate the amyl you have there's the
default configuration let me just go
back into this configuration here so
this extends configuration what does
configuration look like if you look at
the source here we've actually got these
HTTP configurations and login
configurations that are part of the drop
wizard standard and so you can choose to
add configuration details about these in
your Gamal
you can choose to update them add more
threads you know whatever change your
login configuration or not you're gonna
get this config for free and you can get
this config translation for free but
otherwise you've set up the various
special things about your application
that you need to configure your
databases there's a there's a standard
database configuration that you can use
if you're using messaging and Kewpie or
rabbitmq or whatever
you want to set up a messaging broker to
pass into your resource so that your
resource it's being configured by the
actual framework right so again this
resource takes a template that is
telling it how to render its strings you
filled the configuration you grab your
template configuration out of there you
add a health check around your template
this is just sort of a joke health check
but this is where you would add all the
health checks for your environment right
so you have an environment we have a
template health check what does that do
it just makes sure that the template is
something meaningful and then you you
add the resource for your new hello
world resource if you had other
endpoints other paths you would create
those resources configure them and add
them to the environment here once you're
done you go and you build you build a
package so one thing about drop wizard
is that the default way of using it is
to build a fat jar so you're building
using this shaded thing where it pulls
in all the dependencies into one big
gigantic jar as opposed to relying on
pulling maven jars into your individual
environments you can just deploy the one
single jar and then you run it by
targeting the jar saying server is the
only option and putting in your yeah mol
example that yeah my let me show you the
yam on here so here's what the Yamma
looks like the really most interesting
part of it is this is what we had the
template and the default name if I I've
got your comma stood out the default
name so if the default name is commented
out it's gonna use the default from our
configuration file that default value
these configurations are all the HTTP
configurations that you can change
including the port and the admin port
the threads this is all just sort of
default stuff you can override it or you
can leave it so I run my jar and this is
what you're gonna see on the screen when
you run they have a fun banner always
fun it
shows you the get put and post endpoints
that you have there's also a task in
here and that's sort of a default task
you're starting a user port on port 8080
and you're starting an admin port on
port 8081 and so does this look like
this looks like this so what
alright so hello world hello hello
Camille hello Jane hello partner right
all right from default that depart so
what - what does my admin port actually
show me this is the operational menu
that you get by default with job wizard
this is why we like it because of this
operational menu not because it can
produce lovely little JSON here but
because we had this operational menu it
has the metrics this is all the stuff
that they have annotated for you plus
the annotations you added yourselves so
you see this JVM metrics right what's
the current thread count what is you
know information about the logging of
Henders here's my resource and here's
some stuff about it how many times have
been called it's been called four times
what's the min max standard deviation of
the time that it took to run run a
middle second it's kind of slow sitting
it's not doing anything what does my
jetty server look like right here's a
bunch of information about my jetty
server my servlet context handler so
you've got all of these metrics almost
everything in this is coming by default
out of drop wizards annotations itself
that you don't have to put in but now
you've got you know your 500 counts or
400 counts or 200 pounds coming out by
default for you that you can find out
you know oh what's going on
Wow I've gotten a lot of 400s that's not
good it's also has a simple ping yeah
you know your thing is running threads
nice thread dump of your Java threads if
you've ever tried to debug anything you
know that this is nice you don't have to
log onto the server and get a thread
dump there you can just see it right
here see what's going on right look at
that dump all threads
surprise and finally your health checks
so you can have a nag EOS or some other
you know daemon of your choice checking
these health texts making sure
everything looks like it's okay now what
does it look like when it's not okay so
how about if I put some garbage in my
template because that's the only health
check we have kill this control okay I'm
gonna restart it for today I don't have
to actually recompile it because it is
just a configuration so first let's go
to my hello world and I'm getting an
error so what happens when I go to my
health check ah my template has now has
an error right I'm no longer have okay
for all of my health checks I've
actually got an error and this is what
that error is if I were to go to my
metrics you would see in my hello world
resource in that hello exceptions
remember I mentioned we did the
exceptions metered annotation now you
see one because we've gotten an
exception out of that hello world in
point mu that's not good we're just
doing a web scale hello world it's not
web scale right now so so this is drop
alert and a very very brief nutshell I
think the documentation for drop resort
is great but hopefully you see that like
you know is it the absolute simplest
magic out of the box thing you've ever
run no it's not the simplest out of
magic out of the box thing you've ever
run but relatively speaking it's quite
straightforward and simple the biggest
challenges are setting up your config
and sort of gluing it all together and
understanding what it is you need to
configure whether it be your databases
your your messaging queues whatever it
is you're configuring and other than
that it really provides you with a lot
of operational awesomeness straight out
of the box and it's been great for us
we've been really pleased to be using it
so any other questions about the demo
yes
yes that's actually a Jersey so that's
so that's straight from Jersey so I
think so yes and any other questions
about this demo drop litter all right oh
yes yes
uh so the graphite integration I'm not
really gonna be able to show you I can
show you a little bit of the so the
metrics this is like a metric uh sorry
what oh it did okay there we go right so
this is what the annotation looks like
for time so this actually basically I'm
not gonna be able to do this on the fly
but yeah the metrics are sort of baked
in here I didn't bother to bring a code
base that's not drop Azure with metrics
on it that's more about like you create
these static monitors and you register
the metrics into them and then it will
print out the results for you there but
you have sort of static Global's that
own the metrics in those environments
and probably some where are the covers
in here - alright so very quickly you
know my my references to work maybe not
anyway yeah there we go drop wizard code
'hail comm metrics go to hell comm
graphite viki.com i'm not actually gonna
bother to post a demo drop was or
because they drop wizard example in code
as github is plenty good enough that
gives you all the things you really need
thank you so much for coming
Carlo is not here but he did write the
second half of those slides if you have
any questions for him you can find him
at Carlo Barbara on Twitter or cab kata
he's done a few little cool things there
I am scam eel on Twitter I have a blog
that you are more than welcome to read
and make fun of Rent the Runway is
hiring if you think this stuff sounds
like fun if you're interested in you
know helping us stay on the edge of
complexity without falling into the
complexity abyss I would love to talk to
you because I think it's a fun place to
be and I think we're doing some really
fun things
they're so we're hiring you can go to
our careers page or you can just simply
tweet me email me Camille at Apache org
I'm a friendly person come up and talk
to me now thank you guys so much for
coming to talk